die nachrichten des tages heute mit
und willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem donnerstag die vom sport hat
kristin otto erneut fußball guten abend
und das sind unsere wichtigsten themen
heute
kliniken an der belastungsgrenze immer
mehr infektionen braucht das land doch
strengere schutzmaßnahmen
eine zahl die für unermessliches leid
steht mehr als 100.000 menschen sind in
deutschland an oder mit 19 gestorben
werben für die ampel die grünen spitze
präsentiert den mitgliedern den
koalitionsvertrag um ministerposten wird
aber noch gerungen
fast
76.000 kroner neuinfektionen und eine
inzidenz von beinahe
420 jeden tag neue höchstwerte trotz 3g
und all den anderen maßnahmen die lage
ist offenbar so besorgniserregend dass
die geschäftsführende bundeskanzlerin
jetzt alarm schlägt und auf weitere
auflagen drängt und zwar schnell hier
zähle jeder tag aus berlin bin hasher
hinter den kulissen laufen gespräche
zwischen kanzlerin urlaub scholz ampel
parteien und bundesländern angela merkel
macht druck bis forderungen hin zu einem
locker und vor der kamera hält sie sich
zurück sie hat besuch aus polen und sie
ist nur noch geschäftsführend im amt
hier zählt jeder tag wir brauchen mehr
beschränkungen von kontakten viele
länder haben jetzt ja auch zusätzliche
maßnahmen eingeführt und daran da müssen
wir die situation jeden tag sehr
aufmerksam beobachten und ich freue mich
dass ich da einen engen kontakt auch mit
olaf scholz bin der hatte gestern einen
corona krisenstab für das kanzleramt
angekündigt der täglich beraten soll
dass sich in der ampel zweifel breit
machen ob ihr vorgehen ausreicht spricht
heute aus robert habeck heraus
kämpfen wir dafür als gesellschaft als
deutschland im spätherbst 21 darum dass
uns die pauschalen möglichkeiten erspart
bleiben das heißt aber auch dass jede
und jeder dass ihre und das seine tun
muss dass die pandemie gebrochen wird
die ampel fraktionen hatten erst
vergangene woche das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschiedet und
damit einige bisherige maßnahmen
ausgeschlossen aber was nicht mehr geht
ist der lockdown partiell oder umfassend
geschäfte schließen gaststätten
schließen reisen untersagen schulen
schließen und das ist doch ganz
erheblich als ersten bundesländern mit
rekord instanzen kommen hilferufe nach
einem lock down ich halte ihnen dringend
für notwendig weil ich keine andere
möglichkeit mehr sehe kein konsens
darüber aber zwischen den ländern keinen
konsens zwischen der nächsten und alten
bundesregierung
theo koll in berlin was können und was
wollen die regierungsverantwortlichen
jetzt tun
angela merkel hat ja heute angeboten den
von olaf scholz angekündigten krisenstab
sofort einzurichten und zwar noch bevor
die ampel im amt ist aber das verhindert
noch keine einzige ansteckung und die
bisher gültigen 2g und 3g plus regeln
reichen offensichtlich ja auch nicht aus
den dramatischen anstieg zu bremsen
kanzleramtsminister brown fordert jetzt
eine klare notbremse die ampel parteien
wollen sich etwa zehn tage zeit nehmen
um schärfere maßnahmen zu beraten und
damit steigern sie auch zehn tage lang
die politische gefahr in die sie durch
corona geraten denn mit steigenden
infektionszahlen sinkt das zutrauen in
die neue koalition in der lage die von
der künftigen opposition und länderchefs
intensiv genutzt wird der fordern jetzt
politiker weitergehende maßnahmen die
sie längst selbst hätten umsetzen können
aber nicht getan haben jedem anfang
wohnt ein zauber inne hieß es gestern
diesem ampel anfang aber wohnt auch die
schwerste gesundheitskrise inne die
dieses land jemals erlebt hat danke nach
berlin theo koll war das wie ernst die
lage ist zeigt sich auf den
intensivstationen vor allem im süden und
im südosten deutschlands gibt es nur
noch wenige freie betten ab heute werden
deshalb profit patienten von dort in
andere landesteile gebracht nach dem
sogenannten kleeblatt konzept es teilt
deutschland in fünf regionen ist eine
überlastet soll eine andere aushelfen
über den start der krankentransporte in
thüringen melanie haack und daniela
sonntag
aus suhl nach hannover per hubschrauber
geht es für diese thüringer cupid
patienten heute nach niedersachsen
personalmangel und ständig neue fälle
die kliniken in thüringen am anschlag
die verlegung jetzt der letzte ausweg
wir verlegen im grunde genommen die die
verlegung des fähig sind wir erwarten
ungefähr die doppelte anzahl an
patienten die wir in der zweiten und
dritten welle haben das wird also
extremst eng und deswegen fliegen wir
jetzt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt auch schon
aus um die anderen patienten tatsächlich
noch versorgen zu können rund 80
patienten aus thüringen sachsen und
bayern stehen derzeit auf der
verlegungsliste auch die bundeswehr hat
hilfe zugesagt unter anderem steht eine
solche medi weg maschine bereit die
krankenhäuser mobilisieren jetzt alle
reserven wie im thüringer im
kreisklinikum ein viertel der
mitarbeiter hier selbst krank
geschrieben die anderen im notbetrieb
mitarbeiter verzichten auf ihren urlaub
kommen zurück wir haben aufruf gestartet
in den mädchen das doch auch
mitarbeitern die im ruhestand sehen wir
zurückkommen unterstützen planbare op
sollen bundesweit verschoben werden das
haben die länder gesundheitsminister
heute besprochen chefarzt laubinger in
suhl hofft dass ihm die triage erspart
bleibt ich hoffe dass wir eine höhere
impfquote in diesem in dieser region
wirklich erreichen ich wünsche mir dass
die menschen sich vor weihnachten bitte
alle impfen lassen die thüringer
patienten ist mittlerweile in hannover
gelandet weitere transporte sind schon
geplant
jeden tag verlieren in deutschland
menschen den kampf gegen korona seit
heute sind es mehr als 100.000 genauer
100.000 119 menschen starben seit beginn
der pandemie an oder mit cupid 19 vor
allem die älteren haben den virus oft
nichts entgegenzusetzen mehr als
84.000 todesopfer waren über 70 jahre
alt das sind die zahlen hinter ihnen
verbergen sich lauter einzelne
schicksale jutta sonne wald
hannes schedel liebte die berge und die
natur ganz gleich zu welcher jahreszeit
er war sportlich unternehmenslustig und
voller tatendrang mit seiner frau anita
bereiste er nicht nur die fernsten
zipfel der welt die transalp gemacht was
sie nur so von von er wollte noch an den
gardasee dann dementsprechend über die
alpen haben wir die tour gemacht das war
hart und sehr sehr viel freude gemacht
dass wir das auch dieses ziel gemeinsam
erreicht haben hannes schedel war
mediziner und leitete zuletzt eine
eigene klinik in der nähe von passau
dort haben sich er und seine frau anita
vermutlich im märz letzten jahres mit
dem corona virus infiziert ich habe mir
ein stück schneller erholt und leider
hat sich beim mann mann mann keine
besserung eingestellt und es kamen dann
diese atemnot die kurzatmigkeit und dann
kommt ihm da diese verläufe die wir
jetzt auch besser kennen dazu da musste
man eben auch stationär aufgenommen
werden acht tage später stirbt hannes
schedel im alter von 59 jahren nach
anderthalb jahren der pandemie gibt es
impfstoffe viele geimpfte aber auch eine
vierte welle und hartnäckige impfwillige
für anita schiri unverständlich meiner
einstellung ja sage ich dann wenn ich
dazu etwas beitragen kommt um andere und
mich selber in einer gewissen weise zu
schützen dann sollte ich das tun und das
kann man in form einer impfung mit
sicherheit auch tun noch heute kämpft
anita schädel mit den spätfolgen von
corona und der sehnsucht nach ihrem mann
mein mann wird in meinem herzen bleiben
und wird meine große liebe bleiben er
war mein lebenstraum an und mein ein und
alles anita schädel wir nach vorne
schauen sie hat in münchen eine
selbsthilfegruppe für angehörige von
corona opfern gegründet um anderen
betroffenen zu helfen bei der trauer und
der heilung
für viele eltern ist es eine
erleichterung auch kinder ab fünf jahren
können wohl bald gegen korona geimpft
werden in israel und den usa zum
beispiel ist der impfstoff von biontech
bereits für 5 bis 11 jährige zugelassen
heute hat auch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde grünes licht gegeben
konkret geht es um knapp 5,3 millionen
kinder zum vergleich die zahl aller
ungeimpften liegt derzeit bei 24,8
millionen noch vor dem jahreswechsel
will die ständige impfkommission eine
empfehlung aussprechen christopher rente
auch in europa beginnt bald die korona
impfung der fünf- bis elfjährigen wie
momentan schon in den usa kanada und
israel kann durch die ehemals zulassung
der impfstoff von beyond advisor nur
noch offiziell kinder verabreicht werden
so wie bei vielen anderen krankheiten
gegen die wir impfen überwiegt der
nutzen der impfung in meinen augen ganz
eindeutig
die probleme die vielleicht damit
zusammen hängen können die
zulassungsstudie von bayern tech weiter
ergab eine wirksamkeit von 90 prozent
und eine gute verträglichkeit laut
hersteller hatte impfstoff dieselbe
zusammensetzung wie der für erwachsene
die dosis jedoch ist nur ein drittel so
hoch also statt 30 10 mikrogramm
wir müssen das im familienrat nochmal
beschließen wenn der impfstoff da ist
und wahrscheinlich lassen wir es machen
ich wollte diese stiko meldung abwarten
weil ich denke wenn man schon so eine
kommission hat dann möchte ich die auch
nehmen und wissen was die was sie davon
denken jetzt will die stiko die ständige
impfkommission prüfen ob sie eine
generelle impfempfehlung ausspricht
wovor wir sorge haben dass wir halt
unerwartet schwere impfkomplikationen
erleben wie zum beispiel die
herzmuskelentzündung bei jungen
erwachsenen und jugendlichen was ja auch
dazu geführt hat dass wir der
einschränkungen ausgesprochen haben für
den moderner impfstoff und das wissen
wir bei dieser altersgruppe bisher noch
nicht bis zum 20 dezember will die stiko
entscheiden bis dahin sollen daten aus
den usa ausgewertet werden dort sind
bisher schon rund drei millionen kinder
geimpft worden bis dann will auch bei
antec die ersten kinder impfdosen für
deutschland liefern
wenn sie fragen haben zur impfung von
kindern können sie diese stellen an den
präsidenten der gesellschaft für kinder
und jugendmedizin in einem zdf- heute
live um 19 30 in unserer app oder auf
den social media kanälen
der koalitionsvertrag steht unklar ist
allerdings noch wer genau minister oder
ministerin wird in der ampel regierung
bei den grünen sollte das eigentlich
seit stunden bekannt sein doch
überraschend verzögert sich die
abstimmung der mitglieder über den
vertrag und über die besetzung der fünf
grünen ministerien denn die präsentation
der ministerliste steht weiter aus
patricia wiedemeier
von aufbruch von neuem schwung ist heute
beim bund länder treffen der grünen
wenig zu spüren der start der ampel
scheint schwieriger als erwartet zu
werden wir starben möglicherweise
diese regierung in der schwersten
gesundheitskrise die deutschland jemals
hatte zudem gibt es oft bei der
besetzung der fünf grünen ministerien
eigentlich sollten die namen heute
nachmittag um 16 uhr dann um 1730
verkündet werden inzwischen wurde es
auch morgen früh verschoben nur einige
wenige namen des neuen kabinetts stehen
bisher fest sicher ist dass olaf scholz
kanzler wird bei den grünen robert
habeck wirtschafts und klimaminister
annalena baerbock außenministerin werden
um die übrigen drei ministerien wird
derzeit noch gestritten es gibt vier
namen die gehandelt werden zu wenig
linke zu viele real los ein altes uhr
grünes problem bei der fdp dagegen alles
klar christian lindner soll
finanzminister werden volker wissing
marco buschmann und bettina stark
watzinger übernehmen verkehr justiz und
bildungsministerium bleiben sechs
ressorts für die spd gesetz scheint
hubertus heil zu sein die übrigen namen
folgen wohl erst am parteitag anfang
dezember
viele offene personalien viele probleme
die grüne parteivorsitzende gibt sich
trotzdem optimistisch wir sind überzeugt
das ist heute auch hier erst der anfang
für eine gute regierung die richtig was
verändern können und zwar wenn wir das
gemeinsam angehen vorausgesetzt die
grünen schaffen es bis morgen früh eine
lösung bei der verteilung der posten zu
finden und damit den streit zu beenden
ja fragen der kontrolle banerjee in
berlin was ist da los bei den grünen
es geht um den posten des
landwirtschaftsministers um den sich
gerade zwei männer streiten nämlich auf
der einen seite anton hoch breiter
landwirtschafts experte der grünen und
vertreter des linken flügels und auf der
anderen seite cem özdemir der in der
wahl nicht nur ein hervorragendes
ergebnis erzielt hat sondern auch einen
migrationshintergrund mitbringen würden
also beide würden jeweils zu einer
quotenerfüllung sozusagen beitragen das
problem dabei gäbe man müsste mir diesen
posten dann könnten alte grabenkämpfe
wieder aufflammen innerhalb der grünen
nämlich dann wenn man den linken nicht
gleichzeitig einen ausgleich im kabinett
gibt und das ist das letzte was die
grünen jetzt gerade brauchen wo sie
unter beweis stellen wollen dass sie
regierungsfähig sind und es kommt noch
ein weiteres problem dazu das ganze muss
bis spätestens morgen geklärt sein denn
dann soll die urabstimmung beginnen die
auch darüber entscheidet ob die grünen
mitglieder ja sagen zur kabinettsliste
der grünen wenn das nicht klappt dann
schwankt der ganze zeitplan für die
kanzlerwahl
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
berlin und helaba nati
an der beller russisch polnischen grenze
sitzen seit wochen migranten fest immer
wieder versuchen einige den stacheldraht
wall in richtung eu zu überwinden
brüssel wirft dem belarussischen
machthaber lukaschenko vor die
geflüchteten als druckmittel zur grenze
geschleust zu haben dort kämpfen sie
jetzt bei eisigen temperaturen ums
überleben anne brühl
dort wo
trauerfeier für ein wenige tage altes
baby einer syrischen familie das jüngste
todesopfer an der polnisch bella
russischen grenze eltern und geschwister
hatten tagelang in den wäldern
ausgeharrt bis sie von helfern gefunden
wurden
wir beten für sie damit sie durchhalten
frau ließ sich jemand eine lösung für
diese menschen ausgedacht habe für mich
eine fusion sonne täglich veröffentlicht
der polnische grenzschutz bilder wie
diese belarussische soldaten die die
polen mit lasern blenden und die immer
wieder flüchtlingsgruppen über die
absperrungen helfen in berlin betont der
polnische ministerpräsident seine
entschlossenheit
wir verteidigen die eu-außengrenze also
verteidigen wir deutschland vor einer
großen welle von flüchtlingen
hilfsorganisationen kritisieren nach
warschau sie schätzen dass tausende
menschen sich in den polnischen wäldern
verstecken aus furcht zurück nach
belarus geschickt zu werden
polen hat eine sperrzone eingerichtet
verweigert journalisten und helfern den
zugang wir haben die zwei forderungen
der eine ist dass wir zugang bekommen zu
dieser sperrzone und die zweite
forderung ist dass menschen die
möglichkeit bekommen einen asylantrag zu
stellen in polen und dass diese anträge
vernünftig transparent geprüft werden
dann könnten wir glaube ich die lage
hier verbessern darauf hofft auch die
muslimische gemeinde in bonn niki vier
gräber von geflüchteten gibt es schon
auf ihrem friedhof jedes eines zu viel
27 migranten ertranken gestern im
ärmelkanal jetzt weise sich
großbritannien und frankreich
gegenseitig die schuld zu
premierminister johnson sagte paris tue
zu wenig um die illegalen überfahrten zu
verhindern paris dagegen fordert von
großbritannien härter gegen die
hintermänner der schleuser vorzugehen
mehrere mutmaßliche schleuser habe man
gestern festgenommen einer soll aus
deutschland kommen
in sibirien sind bei einem
bergwerksunglück mindestens 14 menschen
ums leben gekommen 35 weitere stecken
noch in der mine fest offenbar war 250
meter unter tage kohle staub in brand
geraten über das belüftungssystem soll
sich das feuer dann schnell in der mine
ausgebreitet haben die rettung der
eingeschlossenen ist derzeit
unterbrochen zu groß die
explosionsgefahr heißt es mehr als 200
kumpel konnten vorher in sicherheit
gebracht werden
und damit sind wir jetzt beim sport
christin und bei der fußball champions
league kann ich habe das gute zu ernst
jubel und erleichterung bei rb leipzig
nach dem 15 0 triumph beim belgischen fc
brügge die torausbeute ein rekord in der
leipziger europapokal-geschichte
beeindruckend der enorme teamgeist durch
den die europa league nun greifbar nah
ist
ausgelassene stimmung bei den leipziger
nach dem spiel die spieler und trainer
achim beierlorzer der gestern den
corinna bedingt fehlen den jazz vertritt
haben richtig spaß leipzig
ersatzgeschwächt neben und auf dem rasen
trotzdem sind sie den belgien gestern
haushoch überlegen kongo mit dem 1 0 in
der zwölften minute fünf minuten später
foul an leipzigs probe strafstoß leipzig
forsberg verwandelt diesen sicher
kombinationsfußball und effektive
abschlüsse silber verwertet nach einer
knappen halben stunde mit schönem
kopfball die flanke von andre linie
achim beierlorzer sieht die beste
leipziger halbzeit dieser
champions-league-saison forsberg erhöht
in der nachspielzeit des ersten
durchgangs auf vier zu null trainer
beierlorzer mit erklärungsversuch
krone hat wenn ich jetzt so betrachte im
nachgang hat es die mannschaft dazu
gebracht für die anderen zu kämpfen und
taktik hin oder her das was die
mannschaft heute auf dem platz gebracht
hat war absolute mentalität und sie
haben füreinander gearbeitet
mentalität und arbeit vor allem aber
ganz viel fußball gucke immer wieder
hart attackiert von den belgiern mit der
richtigen reaktion in der nachspielzeit
fünftes leipziger tor die sachsen sehr
zur freude der mitgereisten mit starken
leistungen und sehr guten chancen in der
europa league zu überwintern
hängende köpfe dagegen bei borussia
dortmund nach dem 1 3 bei portugals
meister sporting lissabon der bvb ist
vor dem letzten gruppenspiel raus aus
der attraktiven königsklasse das hat
marco rose sich anders vorgestellt nur
zwei siege aber elf gegentore in der
gruppenphase das reicht nicht wurden der
champions league überwintern das ziel
haben wir verpasst das ist schon
ein herber schlag nico schulz macht mit
diesem fehler den weg frei für sporting
und das 1 0 durch pedro goncalves auch
sein zweites tor macht deutlich wo die
dortmunder abwehr verwundbar ist
es darf niemals so passieren das müssen
wir viel besser verteidigen es ist eine
zeitweise hitzige partie die von rot für
emre chan und dem elfmeter zum 13 0
gekrönt wird auch der ehrentreffer von
daniel malen zum 1 3 kann das aus für
dortmund und dem abstieg in die europa
league nicht verhindern und gern auch
dieser hinweis alle spiele alle tore vom
fünften spieltag der champions league
finden sie zusammengefasst in der zdf-
heute- app und auf zdf heute.de dort ist
man also ganz nah dran am ball und das
schöne ist wann immer man will ich danke
gerne macht beim rausgehen morgen bei
frost und schnee wird es rutschig mehr
zum wetter hat gleich aus dem verlies
marietta slomka begrüßt sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn hier
übernimmt morgen mit risiken alles gute
ihnen und einen schönen namen noch auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter tiefs übernehmen die regie
zumindest beim wetter und dieser tiefste
ziehen von norden weiter südwärts bringt
halten luft und auch schnee mit schnee
gibt auch von süden her mit diesem
gefangenen tief über die mittelmeerraum
das schiebt es über die alpen zu uns in
den süden deutschlands schauen wir mal
auf die karte für die nach dem norden
gibt es einige schauer im norden sonst
viele wolken aber im süden kommt der
schnee schon auf mit dem tief über dem
mittelmeer ja und dann wird es auch
rutschig bei temperaturen bis minus 4
grad wird es eisig kalt sonst
frostfreien den küsten mit zwei bis vier
grad und morgen im tagesverlauf weiterer
schneefall im südosten deutschlands
natürlich mit straßenglätte ja etwas
regen und schnee kommt auch in den
westlichen mittelgebirgen auf bis auf
300 meter herab fällt da der schnee die
temperaturen dazu bis minus 1 grad
maximal am alpenrand hier häufig im
südosten teils frostig 6 grad an der
nordsee bleibt ein thema und fällt
teilweise in den nächsten tagen bis in
tiefere lagen vor allem im westen und im
süden ein bis fünf grad am samstag ja
und ab sonntag ebenfalls weiterer schnee
damit ein schöner abend